le couple up et bien le gâteau de
l'alsace symbole de l'hospitalité
alsacienne depuis des siècles il prend
part à tous les événements glorieux ou
joyeux de l'histoire de la province
l'origine du moule très lointaine se
situe probablement en alsace et la
recette est alsacienne est depuis deux
siècles au moins cette recette nous
vient sans doute d'autriche de pologne
où l'on a employé la levure de bière
pour faire lever les gâteaux bien avant
qu'on ne l'ait fait en alsace marie
antoinette à qui la ville de strasbourg
réservé à son arrivée un accueil
fastueux et méditons beaucoup le kouglof
de son pays natal et elle mis à la mode
en france en alsace le kouglof a acquis
des lettres de noblesse et il est de
toutes les fêtes officielles et
populaires
il est partout où règnent l'amitié et la
joie il est la majestueuse et bon enfant
la recette du kougelhopf autrichien
recettes rustique est très proche de la
recette classique alsacienne telles
qu'elles figurent dans le livre de
marguerite h purines édité en 1811 à
mulhouse
pour faire un bon coup de bluff outre du
lait tiède et de la levure de bière
il faut bien sûr de la farine du beurre
ramolli et du sucre en poudre des yeux
des raisins secs des noix ou des amendes
par des lilas devenu tellement vite et
le lait doit être bien accueillie avec
les y est c'est très important chouih
très important et puis je mélange avec
la farine le sucre de façon officielle
le terrain il faut des veillées la vue
voilée si vous voulez
un signe
maintenant on a beau faire pareil si tu
te fais ça fais tes mains alors vous
travaillez la pâte maintenant que nous
avons ajouté les yeux pendant combien de
temps
trois minutes à peu près déçu lancaster
fidèles ont déjà envahi ces fiches a
commencé comme ça comment vous apercevez
que la parquet est assez travaillé si
elle essaie de plus oui s'il se détache
de vos si oui c'était h bien et blu
situe là alors tous à 100 g de farine
nous avons mis
80 g de beurre oui en pommade entrant
madoui et puis il ya dans ce bilan pour
mille en valeur mais je sais comme sel
et la levure délayée 25 g de levure oui
c'est un prime de sucre oui on travaille
la pâte et 82 lèvres eh oui il serait
sage femme et tout à la fin arnaud
guérin
oui un peu plus
jamila maintenant elle est arrêtée
on va la laisser aux et combien tu 1,38
à peu près ça dépend il faut pendre une
température tiède y est douce
la saveur incomparable du coup glop est
due à de simples produits du terroir
alsacien pour le préparer on choisit la
farine la meilleure blanche et légères
obtenu en broyant des grains de blé
sélectionné comme ici dans ce moulin de
cunix bruch bastille sur la solaire
alors c'est pas elle a bien levé elle
est très belle alors maintenant parler
mais le carton rouge est en valeur et
des moules
enfin les garnir avec des noirs alors là
qu'on peut ré toujours plusieurs boules
ya un moule pour la famille pour les
adultes et l'autre pour les enfants
c'est pour les enfants que pour faire
plaisir aux enfants ils sont toujours
impatients ils ont toujours leurs
doublures ce avant les autres hormis le
fonds vendôme est aussi les amarres de
ville ou mettez des noix oui puisque
nous on utilise ce qu'on a chez nous
fait un bond avait toujours beaucoup de
noir cependant l'effet des voiliers dans
divers très bon
alors je travaille en fait la femme
depuis je l'aimé tant
remplissez autre intérêt votre carte
voilà un personnage allait nous allons
remettre dans la vitrine
oui sauf est un peu pour laisser lever
encore une demi-heure encore ça fait pas
mal d attente est battu à vichy c'est
bientôt la caméra en plus bien louis
houle oui aux pauvres
c'est en alsace que se font les moules à
coup bloc et cela depuis des siècles
soufflenheim village au nord de
strasbourg était connu pour ses ateliers
de poterie déjà au moyen-âge la
corporation des potiers et a été fondée
au 12e siècle on utilise la terre
réfractaire de soufflenheim et les
moules sont tournés à la main comme
autrefois
la forme et le moule c'est très
important il faut qu'il soit absolument
terre laisse paris où qu'ils soient en
terre parce que si vous avez un mourut
en métal le couple ont fui trop vite et
à ce moment-là l'intérieur n'est pas
cuit et l'extérieur et brûlés alors il
faut absolument un moule en terre de
soutenable bien entendu régional sachs
est témoin
la première fois qu'on les utilise il
faut d'abord les brûler c'est à dire
comme comme une vie il faut la culotté
il faut mettre du beurre dans les
papiers dans un truc très chaud une ou
deux fois sinon recoupements sortant
alors voulait brûler une deux voies et
après vous pouvez mettre votre pack
dedans et la cuisson est aussi très
importante
est-ce qu'il faut que le fonds soit très
chaud la maison est très importante il
faut pas cuire dans un four trop froid
notre coup cloud seconde de trop il faut
un pour mettre en moyen 10 ans
230 à 240 degrés pour une ménagère c'est
ce qui correspond à peu près aux ben tu
as 25 minutes depuis son quadruple moyen
qui avait 300 g de pain pour la recette
du couple ou alors nous allons vendre
500 g de bonne farine que vous avez pas
miser dans un cul de poule ou bien dans
une jatte et c'est ça c'est la recette
que je vous donne pour les ménagères
alors vous mettez donc face au drame de
paris ensuite pouvait teddy g de sel 80
g de sucre environ 40 g de levure de
bière et ensuite vous mettez environ 200
g de lait vous pouvez en mettre un peu
plus sous forme et à deux mois suivant
la consistance la farine et le degré
d'humidité vous faites vous faites une
batte pas trop ferme et en faites pas
vous ajoutez votre beurre plus 150 g de
les amis les suites aline foot les
réseaux de malaga et ensuite vous mettez
votre pâte a monté une fois que votre
façade ou les volumes à rabat et à
l'aneth et l'egypte ans pour qu'elle
reprenne peu près son volume de départ
et ensuite vous la requête portait au
moment où elle redémarre
vous la mettez à fondre la dans votre
for mac do et nous l'a laissé monter à
peu près à ras du rata forte et une fois
qu'elle est enfant ou la mettais dans un
four environ 220 à 230 degrés il
correspond un tour de ménage trois
quarts de la chaleur maximum
d'habitude en alsace on achète le coup
double samedi pour être consommés au
petit déjeuner du dimanche matin
familial c'est à dire que toute la
famille se réunit au moment où on boit
le café et qui en mangeaient une tranche
de google ou